you guys asked for it so here it is in
front of me i have two m2 macbook pros
both with eight gigs of ram one with 256
gigs of storage the infamous slow ssd
and one with the upgraded 512 gigabyte
option which costs 200 more today we
will find out does the ssd speed really
matter when there's no other variables
whatsoever how much of a difference is
there and also i want to add in new
information that nobody else has tested
or talked about and also give you guys
some helpful tips on how to make your
base model m2 that has the slow ssd
quicker how to make sure it doesn't slow
down significantly like we've seen in
other videos now i have to be honest and
i have to say that i am sick of making
videos on this topic and this will be
the last one which is why i'm gonna make
it a great one
we didn't want to get into any of this
it's just when we noticed that it was
being slow when we opened it up we saw
it and then people had so many comments
so many questions while at the same time
you had other reviewers saying that it
doesn't make a big difference in the
real world so of course we had to test
and follow up and after that you guys
started asking more questions well how
do we make it better can you stick with
eight gigs of ram now i believe it is
our job as our viewers to do high
quality detailed real world testing to
help inform you guys on how to best
spend your hard earned money and as we
have been making these videos that
you've been asking about we've made a
lot of discoveries some of which
disprove other reviewers opinions now we
don't like any drama any beef
we just want to do good quality work and
make videos that we would want to watch
that would help us we've been doing this
for years now and of course this stirs
up some trouble but a lot of people are
me watching these videos and millions of
people are gonna be buying these
macbooks like apple said the macbook pro
is the second best-selling laptop out
there so we want to make sure when
people are buying them they know which
one they need to buy now as we've been
making these videos and following up to
thousands of comments and answering your
questions we've made videos like why is
the m2 slower the ultimate comparison
which is true and then you guys along
with reviewers wanted real world proof
because some tech reviewers didn't
believe that ssd matters it's okay that
apple did it so we showed it to you guys
with analytics open activity monitor
swap data and comparing to the m1 which
is slower
but when you load up the ram or using
swap the m2 macbook pro is actually
slower than the m1 we compared it to the
14 inch where when it converted 8k canon
raw files the fan couldn't keep up at
full speed and the whole system slowed
down the cpu and gpu basically shut off
to keep itself from going over 108
degrees celsius at which point people
are saying all right well yes this is
all true but your titles are just going
over the top where it's exactly what is
in the video and of course everybody
else that makes videos also has titles
that grab attention because that's how
youtube's algorithm works i don't know
maybe we're covering these topics in too
much detail and too fast you guys let me
know what you think down below and with
all of that said let's see how much of a
difference this makes and answer the
question once and for all as far as the
straight up ssd speeds we have 1361
right compared to 2300 and 1481 read
compared to
2740. so just like we told you in our
previous videos if you get the 512 you
will get two of those nand chips with
much faster performance but let's see
how much of an impact that makes for
real world tasks i'm transferring a 42
and a half gig video file which is
completely normal for us a lot of them
are actually larger and as we're nearing
the end of the transfer you see that the
ssd is actually writing at about 200
megabytes per second not the 1300 that
we saw and this is one thing that a lot
of reviewers don't talk about it is slc
cache where with these ssds that are
cheaper
which are the majority of them only a
portion can write really fast and then
after a certain amount is filled it
slows down now with the 512 model not
only are the ssds faster which we're
actually not maxing them out because our
external drive is slower but the slc
cache is larger so we could do this
whole transfer without slowing down
which is why it took only 23 seconds to
do 45 gigs compared to 2 minutes and 17
seconds now that is a massive difference
and some people of lines have said hey
well the m2 ssd still transfers faster
than the m1 but there's a big caveat you
have to have your hard drives filled
similarly for it to be accurate because
if your m1 is filled with a bunch of
apps bunch of programs it will slow down
earlier than the brand spanking new m2
macbook pro that only has mac os
installed on it but if you're somebody
that's getting along with the base model
you're gonna have it filled up or close
to filled up in order to survive on that
amount now this one wasn't filled up all
the way we have 96 gigabytes of
documents on here which is realistic
that's less than one video project or if
you go out and you do a photo shoot with
raw files it takes up a good amount of
space and then 58 gigs of apps which a
lot of these are the ones that come with
it of course we have lightroom we have
photoshop we have xcode final cut
nothing excessive we sell a lot that we
did not install now what happens if we
just go ahead and delete our pc test
folder which is pretty much all of those
documents and we tried doing the
transfer again well that took 32 seconds
much closer to the 23 that the 512 got
and of course the 512 could be faster if
we had a faster external ssd now this
just proves why some people are saying
no the transfers are quick they got a
brand new machine and they didn't put
files on there or programs it's going to
perform better but as soon as you load
it up it will slow down significantly as
you guys saw so if you want your base
model m2 to work faster well don't keep
a lot of files on it make sure that at
least half of it is free so basically
install a couple programs a few small
files that keep everything else external
which is a major bummer because the m1
wouldn't slow down as much and this
brings us to the slc cache my only other
pci express 3.0 512 gig is my intel 16
inch
which came out a couple years ago and
with that once the ssds slowed down they
would still run at about 900 megabytes
per second i should stay above that
whereas with these new machines even the
512 the ssds are not as good which is
why they slowed down to about 350 or so
for the 512 and then the 256 slows down
in the 200 megabyte per second range
which is slower than a regular sata ssd
it is crazy slow now with that we have
other metrics as well not only
sequential writes which is why when
we're using swap these ssds are acting
much slower than you would expect them
to now i get what some of the apple
apologists are saying and that's that
128 gig nand flashes aren't really
available anymore so apple had to go
with a single 256 gigabyte but take a
look at this you can get a 256 gig by
m.2 for 21
it's not the price point that is getting
them in supply chain these are readily
available and this isn't a sucky one
this is faster than what apple is using
and it's tlc not the cheaper qlc and it
has a controller and a stick in shipping
and profit for amazon for 21
if apple had to go away from the 128 gig
nand modules and go with 256 so they
only put one in put in two make the base
model 512 just like dell is doing with
their xps 13 plus that has much faster
speeds pci express 4 for that kind of
base price point apple can afford it and
the market price for one of these 256
gig tlc chips is 2 dollars and 4 cents
now i want to run lightroom as a
baseline because with a 16 gig model we
saw that it was almost twice as fast so
before we open up some web browsing
tests like everybody does let's export
these 50 images as you guys could see
both systems are using close to four
gigs of swap so right now the only
difference are the ssds everything else
is identical the 256 gig model took two
minutes to export these 50 images while
the 512 took a minute and 45 seconds
that is a performance difference of 15
and that is without having anything else
open no web browsing no other
applications exact systems only the
difference in ssd man back in the day
when we would get a new intel macbook
pro 15 would have been an amazing
improvement just you know year after
year or two years later sometimes it was
10
and here with just an ssd upgrade that's
how much of a difference we're seeing so
there you go to those of you guys that
say it doesn't make a difference in the
real world and now i'm going to open
just 10 web browsing tabs i usually use
more than that but we're going to keep
it simple here just like we did in our
last video and i have my google drive
open my channel analytics a youtube
video playing in the background i have
ign open electric just a normal amount
of tabs unless you guys use way less
just two or three let me know down below
let's hit export over here now we're
using over five gigs of swap on both and
when i'm rendering i'm usually on the
internet i'm writing some emails not
just sitting there and of course usually
it's more than 50 photos so let's check
out our responsiveness right now let's
go ahead and switch over to say my
google drive
okay that was pretty similar on both
let's go to ign a little bit faster
there on the 512 model
electric
same thing
similar there at the last one
the verge i would say pretty similar oh
interesting for the youtube video the
512 one is running it this one is not
paused
but for some reason it's not playing all
right it's
being stuttery there you go all right so
our five 12 gig model is done let's wait
for the base and bam it is done and guys
i'm quite shocked so we have
four minutes and 20 seconds for the 512
m2 yes it slowed down dramatically
not having enough ram and i believe that
the m2 chip needs more ram than the m1
we have higher performance higher
bandwidth but the mount isn't enough
now with the 256 gig model with 8 gigs
this one took
7 minutes and 43 seconds that is almost
80 percent faster and the only
difference is
that one of these has a two nan chip set
up just like the m1 has and the new m2
base has a single one that is slower
there is proof that with only 10 web
browsing tabs open we're not going
extreme we are seeing an 80
difference so yes this is a big deal
this does matter and people should be
upset with this
change now with the m1 when i did my 8
vs 16 gig comparison and we also had
double the storage we only saw i believe
it was like a 10 difference between the
uh 8 gig and the 16 gig with double the
ssd and then when we loaded everything
up we didn't do 10 web browsing tabs we
had 25 20 in chrome five in safari and i
had four pro applications open and even
then
the the performance difference uh only
then it kind of stretched out to being
twice as slow and that's also with
doubling of the ram in a way way harder
load here we're seeing an 80 difference
that's crazy now for those of you saying
that nobody buys the base model who
would do that what person that wants to
do some photo editing would do that
well
we were quite surprised when we looked
at our affiliate analytics and we saw
that from our audience those that are
into tech those are doing things like
that
almost three times more of them bought a
base model compared to buying one that
is specked up now imagine the average
joe that just goes to an apple store or
costco or best buy and with that the
base models are the ones that are
stocked everywhere you can't go buy a 16
gig model
in the store and that takes a week so
people just pick up what there is
thinking it's going to work well and it
did with the m1 the swap worked great
now with these m2 macbook pro
specifically the base model is number 17
on amazon top 100 laptop sales charts
whereas the 512 option is number 73
far far away from the base and those are
both kept in stock on amazon and with
that the people that are buying one of
these they're people that are interested
in tech they've probably been waiting
for a while for this to come out not the
average joe that doesn't need
performance that randomly chose to buy
one because his old one died or
something else happened these are people
that are more than likely in the know
and they're buying base models and with
the m1 macbook air i've done a bunch of
this kind of stuff video editing photo
editing with web browsing tabs it
performed a lot better over the last
year and a half and now let's export a
five minute simple 4k project
with just those web browsing tabs open
and final because lightroom is closed
going back to our web browser here we're
getting stuttering with the playback of
this video while we're exporting
compared to just fine over here and then
going through some of our tabs let's go
ahead and press
you guys saw the difference right there
opening up that one
there you guys go you guys see it for
yourselves this shows the result of
using a single nand chip with much
slower ssd performance in the real world
and bam right there the 8 gig 512 model
did slow down ended up taking two
minutes and 50 seconds
instead of two minutes and 23 with just
final cut open
but the 256 gig model took
four minutes and
23 seconds and this is only a five
minute clip without anything else open
we don't have photoshop or lightroom
open anything like that
so how can we make this better well
first off you could just shut down all
of your web browsing tabs make sure you
only have
one app open final cut if you want to
get the best performance and in that
case they will perform the same my other
suggestion is to use safari instead now
we use chrome because we like it and
because most of you guys do as well
reports came out last month showing that
by far most people use chrome and only
about nine percent of people use safari
i closed chrome and opened up the
identical tabs in safari instead and now
let's export those same 50 images where
previously we saw a difference of 80
percent
with just lightroom open rendering and
those 10 chrome tabs all right the 512
model is finished it took 3 minutes and
13 seconds which is definitely better
than the 4 minutes and 20 seconds i
believe it was with chrome instead of
safari but of course that's still worse
than the minute and 45 when we didn't
have any web browser tabs open at all in
just lightroom and bam the 256 gig is
also done it was quicker than with
chrome 6 minutes 49 seconds compared to
743 with chrome but it is now more than
twice as slow as the 512 model where
before is 80 slower so yes safari helped
a little bit but the difference is
significant three minutes 13 seconds
compared to
649
all with the same exact system the only
difference being the ssd
uh and
just lightroom open and then safari our
final cut is closed in our old m1
comparison video we had four pro apps
open in 25 tabs 20 in chrome and then
five in safari and then the difference
wasn't even twice the speed and that
also had 16 gigs it wasn't only a
storage difference so this just proves
that yes
apple should not have done this with the
ssds this is real world use and i don't
know what we would have gotten if i
would have had four pro apps open in 25
tabs instead swap does matter and the
crazy thing is
even the base m1 ipad air which has 64
gigs of storage this thing gets
1753 read and
2031 right
faster than the fit 256 gig
m2 macbook pro is and apple doesn't even
give the 64 gig option swap because it
wouldn't be fast enough and of course
you need eight gigs of storage for swap
to be able to work but this ssd is
faster on a 600
ipad
compared to
a you know thirteen hundred dollar
laptop nobody and i mean nobody should
buy the base model but unfortunately
millions of people are going to do
exactly that which is why we want to
make these videos to inform people so
please share this video with other
people now what should you do should you
upgrade your ssd absolutely even that
makes a huge difference and if you don't
you need to keep the files off and have
an external ssd anyways if you want it
to transfer without slowing down
dramatically like a showjet to start and
then upgrading your ram also helps a ton
for example under this workload with
chrome the 16 gig 512
it took
one minute and 17 seconds to transfer
way faster than with these systems that
have eight gigs of ram massive
difference but at that point you're
spending seventeen hundred
dollars and the 14 inches available for
200 bucks off in a lot of places
including amazon will have links down
below
so it doesn't make sense so this just
shows that this product is just designed
to get people to spend more money and
then move up to the 14 inch it is not
designed to be a machine that's gonna
work great and not slow down a lot
because as you guys see it has some
serious real world um issues for that
base model so we are done that is it
i think we've proven our case here this
is very unfortunate because we loved
recommending the base model m1 macbook
air in the past we'll see if the m2 also
has these issues and what the temps are
going to be like so click that circle
above if you guys want to see that video
check out one of those great ones right
over here this has been max and i'll see
you in the next video
[Music]